[Música]
quando eu era criança eu acompanhava os
meus pais fazendo visitas em famílias
que viviam em situação de
vulnerabilidade social
e eu comecei a observar que existia uma
realidade muito diferente da minha
eu me lembro que eu fazia visitas em
famílias que moravam em bairros próximos
ao meu e que viviam realidade
completamente diferente de tudo aquilo
que eu vivia
eu fui crescendo falando que eu queria
fazer psicologia porque eu gostava de
ouvir as pessoas e pedir para que os
meus pais me colocassem um colégio que
fosse voltado para o vestibular porque
não queria fazer o ensino médio técnico
eu queria passar por uma faculdade
federal de psicologia
eu fui para o ensino médio voltado para
o pré-vestibular e nesse colégio eu fui
selecionada para participar de um
workshop chamado consciências unidas foi
o workshop elaborado pelo conselho
britânico e aplicado aqui na cidade por
uma volta redonda em si que tinha como
objetivo o protagonismo juvenil
nesse evento ouviram palestras e
elaborações de projetos mas infelizmente
a coisa o evento as pessoas não se
reencontraram para executar as idéias
mas eu continuo continuava muito
entusiasmada queremos ser um agente de
mudança e resolvi reunir os amigos no
ano de 2010 no feriado de finados a fim
de planejar algo social era o mês de
novembro e em dezembro já era o natal
foi quando o projeto em ação foi
idealizado ele tinha como objetivo
principal não levar só algum material
mas leva sempre uma mensagem em ação a
gente queria levar também o verdadeiro
sentido do natal mas o nosso objetivo
também é único é promover o bem comum e
independente de religião
nós fizemos a primeira ação foi
maravilhosa porque a gente começou a
descobrir que a gente poderia ser um
sinal de esperança na vida das pessoas
fazendo muito pouco ea gente decidiu não
parar e fazer as ações em todas as
outras datas comemorativas do ano
eu convidei a organizadora do workshop
para fazer parte do projeto
ela foi se aproximando de mim e me
aconselhou a fazer o curso de
administração pública
eu não conhecia o curso
pesquisei me informei me interessei
passei no vestibular e atualmente está
concluindo a minha graduação em
administração pública por acreditar que
como administradora pública eu posso te
ajudar mais as pessoas ao longo do curso
eu fui vendo que na prática a teoria ela
não acontecia e confessa que se foi
muito decepcionante mas também conhece
um conceito chamado de participação
social que é um conceito que me fazia
ser um agente de mudança e de conseguir
mudar a realidade das pessoas e fazer
com que os direitos garantidos pela
constituição acontecessem com as
experiências do projeto e me
sensibilizei há muitas questões sociais
e comecei a desenvolver meu trabalho de
conclusão de curso com o tema de
saneamento básico
mas ao longo dos meus estudos eu fui
vendo que não bastava falar só do
saneamento porque o saneamento básico
ele gera inúmeras consequências
a falta de saneamento ela está
relacionada à área da educação porque as
crianças que não têm saneamento básico
elas crescem com um défice de
aprendizagem está relacionada ao
trabalho e renda porque as pessoas ficam
doentes e não conseguem é o trabalho
está rolando relacionado à área da
habitação a área da saúde
enfim conclusão acabei mudando meu tema
do tcc para políticas públicas interesse
tori ice falar sobre intersetorialidade
significa dizer que as áreas precisam
funcionar de forma articulada e
descentralizada
não se pode falar de educação
desvinculado da cultura
não se pode falar de esporte
desvinculado do lazer no esporte não se
pode falar de educação sem estar
vinculado à assistência social
existe um programa de governo para
exemplificar o bolsa família
o bolsa família ele foi pensado em uma
forma de atender diferentes áreas
as pessoas que recebem o bolsa família
elas precisam estar com as crianças como
a freqüência escolar
elas precisam estar com o cartão de
vacinação em dia e ter um acompanhamento
junto ao cras que é o centro de
referência de assistência social
então o governo federal
idealizou uma política pública é um
programa pensado de forma intersetorial
enfim
as minhas relações eu acho que não vai
rodar animação mas aqui estão algumas
engrenagens onde elas falam que as
minhas relações humanas me trouxeram
experiências que me fizeram entender que
assim como nas políticas públicas
eu preciso de interação para funcionar
bem que sozinho eu posso até me mover
mas em um coletivo eu posso trazer
movimento pra minha vida mas não só nela
para a vida de outras pessoas também
eu fui tendo resultado surpreendente de
redes intersetoriais começou no ano de
2013 nós conhecemos uma comunidade que
merecia muita atenção mas o grupo não
era grande o suficiente para dar a
atenção que essa comunidade merecia
foi quando o ano de 2015 o grupo se
fortaleceu e voltou nessa comunidade
para dar a atenção que eles mereciam e
nessa comunidade nós ouvimos uma fase
que impactou muito que foi nós
precisamos de presença e não só de
presente
resolvemos aplicar um questionário nessa
comunidade para entender quais eram as
principais demandas que eles tinham que
diante dos nossos olhos
as demandas eram inúmeras eram inúmeras
carências era um esgoto a céu aberto
eram casa de madeira as crianças não
tinha uma ocupação
enfim a gente precisava entender o que
eles enxergavam como algo emergencial e
após a aplicação do questionário
nós tivemos um diagnóstico e resolvemos
dividir o projeto em duas equipes uma
equipe cultural e uma equipe social a
equipe cultural ficou responsável por
realizar oficinas de desenho leitura
futebol música
nós acabamos conquistando espaço ali
naquela comunidade ele cedeu e um
barraco pra gente cediam mesa cadeira
para que a gente pudesse realizar as
oficinas com as crianças mas o barraco
não foi o suficiente
a gente acabou conseguindo também a
chave do ciep para realizar as oficinas
enfim a outra equipe era equipe social
que ficou responsável por acompanhar a
luta por uma moradia digna e desenvolver
um contato maior com os moradores
existe um descaso do poder público há
mais de oito anos com a promessa de
moradia para eles existiam casas que
estavam com obras paradas há muito tempo
foi quando essa equipe social de
voluntários tanto do curso de
administração pública quanto o curso de
direito se fizeram presentes nessas
reuniões junto ao prefeito de barra
mansa para mostrar que a comunidade não
estava sozinho que ela tinha pessoas que
tinham um pouco mais de conhecimento pra
está acompanhando o caso deles as casas
continuavam lá mesmo
eles faziam as promessas mas não há
soluções não vinham
foi quando a comunidade decidiu fazer a
ocupação nessas casas ea gente via que a
gente precisava de alguma forma de dar
essa comunidade mas de forma ilícita
porque haviam empresas que nos apoiavam
existe uma versão de ônibus que fazem o
transporte dos voluntários até essa
comunidade e também uma rede de
supermercado que forneceu antes para
essas crianças
foi quando um membro do projeto levou
pra mídia
o descaso do poder público e surge o
efeito imediato o prefeito com medo da
repercussão do caso retomou as obras
mesmo após a ocupação e falou que ele
não retirar as famílias de lá
aqui estão fotos de antes da ocupação e
depois da ocupação
mesmo após a ocupação eles retomaram a
colocar janelas portas e as pinturas
foram feitas
acabou sendo uma espécie de combustível
para aqueles moradores que até então não
estava mais se movendo por descrença
acabamos conseguindo fazer com que eles
se unissem para lutar por algo que eles
mereciam
agora vocês vão assistir um vídeo onde
duas moradoras da comunidade falam
porque a gente pode se considerar esse
combustível
tenho amor à tarde quando você chega e
se pegar pegar aqui um pouco então
eliminado o resultado né
e vendo um projeto vocês podem também de
ensinar o que é mais uma vez vou fazer
ali não sei que fora de série disse
pelosi
então ele pegou o que vocês conseguem lá
porque eu nunca fui influenciado por
este momento com vocês vocês acham mais
de 90 porque a gente precisava de um
espelho legal e se vocês podem se
inscrever
talvez assim ela pela força que vocês
vieram começando com a gente ea ajuda o
apoio amparo talvez ninguém nunca viu
tocar para o gol
acabamos fazendo parte de um momento
histórico daquela comunidade
percebemos que somando forças juntando
as nossas peças mudanças extraordinárias
acontecem e somos geradores de mudança
pressa para ter uma cidade além do aço
que prevaleçam os vínculos com o
propósito em comum que a gente não seja
peça que se enferruja mas que a gente
possa estar em constante movimento para
ser geradores de mudança para que a
gente possa mudar uma frase que a gente
ouviu que foi minha casa além da vida se
transformado em uma frase minha casa
meus direitos minha vida obrigada
[Aplausos]